Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
and
Ahhh,
just checking in.
Hey,
are you who,
what's going on?
Just checking in on you.
How's your Thursday afternoon going?
Oh,
Billy Billy Ballou.
He left Ireland.
He left Dublin before six.
And um,
now I'm in a,
I'm in London.
I've done,
I flew into a fro.
Yeah.
Um,
the typical Heathrow experiences just,
I just don't fucking understand what the problem is with that Goddamn airport.
I hate that fucking airport.
I love it because I'm going to London,
but I hate it when I get there.
Oh,
I was flying from Dublin to London,
which is like flying from fucking La to San Francisco,
essentially.
Nice,
easy flight.
You're on southwest.
They're doing stand up.
You're waiting for it to be over.
And by the time they've finished their routine,
they're already landing and they've begun where there were now landing routine
with him,
imitate fucking c three Po and fucking Darth Vader or it,
whatever it is that those people are trying to do over there.
MMM.
Anyways,
I guess they feel that there's a lot of nervous flyers over there.
And for some reason,
bad standup comedy is the thing,
I guess.
Then you're not afraid to die because you're like,
well,
at least if the plane crashes,
I don't have to hear the end of this routine.
Oh Bell,
that's no way to,
it's Thursday,
man is supposed to be a happy event.
Yeah.
So anyways,
I'm flying from Dublin and to eighth row and um,
everything's goes great.
Take off on time.
Land a little bit.
Early Gate is ready,
you know.
But I did the unforgivable,
I checked a bag,
which I never do.
I didn't want to do on this trip,
but you know,
my wife talked me into it.
Um,
which I'm actually glad she did.
Once I get the bag and I unpack and actually have some of my stuff,
you know,
I have some options for different outfits.
Sorry.
Um,
so everything goes great.
And then,
you know,
I get off the plane,
I'm standing there,
I get the information.
Oh,
I don't have to go through customs because I was already fucking in Dublin or
whatever,
which I didn't think was part of the,
uh,
the whole Great Britain fucking reach.
I thought,
I would think if I was in Northern Ireland,
if I felt food from Belfast to London,
they'd be like,
all right.
I was in the Republic of Ireland,
you know,
I was there.
They're not part of Great Britain.
Are they are,
they're great.
Britain.
Was,
was,
uh,
England,
Wales,
Scotland,
all the wall and a Northern Ireland,
whatever.
Maybe because I'm in the European Union,
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but then I thought they did the Brexit thing,
but maybe that hasn't happened yet.
I don't know.
All I know is I haven't gone through,
I didn't have to go through customs,
so I was sacked and I go down to the fucking stupid carousel thing,
whatever the baggage claim and it's already turned on.
I'm like,
you fucking kidding me.
And I see three bags come out.
Then there's a little space,
little space,
and I see two bags coming out.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
There were already unloading it.
So I stand there for a good five minutes and it's just those three bags,
little space,
little space that then the two bags and then they start recognizing the bag
saying,
oh,
these are just bags that were sitting here.
You know,
five people didn't make it,
were sold in the human trafficking and they haven't claimed their bags.
I Dunno what the fuck happened,
right?
Um,
or they went ahead of their flight or their bags got on and they did.
And who the fuck knows?
And I was standing there.
10 minutes goes by,
15 minutes goes by,
20 minutes goes by the belts on the same fucking three bags,
a little bit of space or the space of stood out fucking two bags.
And um,
I'm just like,
you know,
this is just every fucking,
I understand that for like 50 fucking minutes.
Wait for my fucking bag.
It's just like that fucking airport.
It just breaks shit,
goddamn spirit.
Cause every fucking time it's a different fuck over and see it.
Never see it coming.
If that always happen,
I would be like,
okay,
here's the deal.
I'm not checking a bag or if I checked the bag,
it'd be like,
just settle in because you know it's going to be 50 minutes.
All right,
go sit down,
get yourself some bangers and mash,
whatever the fuck it is.
These people eat over here and you know,
show up 45 minutes later and pick up your fucking bag.
What killed me is how everybody else just accepted it.
And I was the only person standing there going,
what the fuck is wrong with this airport?
What are they got three fucking baggage handlers
then we'll kill me is when they finally started unloading the bags.
They unload like five of them
and then,
and then you see people on your flight grabbing them and then there's no more
bags for like 10 minutes.
It's like,
what the fuck happened?
The guy doing it just to,
just to have a fucking stroke.
There's nobody back there to help them.
You get like concerned.
MMM.
Oh well I didn't,
wasn't concerned.
I was selfish.
Allah gave you show was about was my bag.
So anyways,
I get my fucking bag
and uh,
I make it over here to the hotel.
And,
uh,
after the night before I was played the three arena in Dublin,
one of my favorite shows,
those fucking people are just,
it's like double specific to Dublin.
They like the best fucking hecklers.
I don't even know how,
but they made like nine 11.
Funny,
just in an absurd way.
I was on stage and I was talking about like how much the country changed,
you know,
since nine 11 when I said nine 11,
somebody in the crowd went,
whew.
You know,
and they might've been in American agreeing like,
Woo.
Yeah.
You know,
the country did really change after that.
Just kind of an obvious statement.
Now that I'm repeating it,
but the way they did it,
it made it seem like they were cheering on nine 11.
So I riffed about that.
I said,
Oh yeah,
you excited about tragedies?
Oh yeah.
I,
you know,
I've always hated skyscrapers and I just said something like that.
It made everybody laugh.
So then I started the joke again.
I to go,
you know,
ever since nine 11,
and then the whole crowd goes,
Woo,
just to be dicks,
you know,
so then I roll with it and I just start,
start every fucking joke now with some American tragedy as go,
yeah,
blah,
blah.
You know,
I believe that was around,
uh,
Pearl Harbor and then they all go,
Woo.
Who's so fucking childish and stupid.
Right.
So after like the third one,
I said,
I go,
you know what,
Ireland,
I really wish I knew about your fucking tragedies.
All right.
But I'm an American.
I don't have time to care about other countries.
And it was just like this little fucking stupid inside back and forth thing that
will never happen at another show.
Um,
and uh,
I dunno,
it was just the classic classic,
Dublin crab.
MMM.
I had such a fucking great,
I came,
it's just such a fucking great city.
So then I go over,
uh,
last night to do Royal Albert Hall and um,
I don't even know how to describe it.
Yeah.
Like,
uh,
I still feel like it was like,
I dreamed it,
like it didn't really,
it went by so God damn fast.
And when you walk in there,
if you're a fan of led Zeppelin,
that place essentially looks the exact same as it did when you watch,
you know,
that concert footage,
the outlet for my money,
the best concert footage of led Zeppelin that exists just the way it looks,
the way it's shot that film.
Um,
I've tried to do a standup special to,
to make it look like that.
You just can't do it.
It's just of that,
yeah,
I guess you'd have to film it,
but,
um,
I just walked right out.
I was like,
John Bonham's fucking that,
that maple kit he had was right fucking here.
It was crazy.
And I remember when,
when I got announced to go out,
I can't remember who was that or not.
There's one word,
Robert plant walks off stage and grabs a joint,
smokes it and holds it up to the camera.
Like,
that's what I thought.
It was such a fucking,
it was the weirdest experience walking out because I felt like I'd been there
already just because I've watched that concert film so many times.
And No,
I didn't get a chance to play drums because,
uh,
I did the show in Dublin the night before,
which I had to do,
cause,
you know,
I had to make sure,
um,
I did one show in Europe,
you know,
there's always that just a little bit of a different vibe.
So I had,
you know,
that was more important,
to have a good show than the,
you know,
go there and hack away at the drums for like an hour.
But,
um,
believe me,
I definitely got my money's worth.
The crowd was fucking amazing.
MMM.
And I just had this whole weird feeling the entire time I was up there.
Like,
why am I so relaxed with the combination of,
Holy Shit,
I'm in Royal Albert Hall
and then,
you know,
actually fucked up a couple of jokes because I was looking at the architecture.
I can't fucking believe I'm here.
Um,
my parents came out,
my wife came out for the show.
MMM.
My manager and agent came out and,
uh,
it was just awesome.
It was like everybody,
you know,
I,
I can't,
if you ever get a chance to come over here and see anything there,
um,
it really is just one of those places.
And I put some photos up on Instagram and
MMM.
Yup.
That's it.
And now,
now Billy boy is on vacation.
I think I did like an hour and 15 minutes in the show and I was sitting there
going,
I forgot to look at my watch.
And I was like,
I can't tell if I've been up here for an hour and a half,
40 minutes,
a half hour or a little over an hour.
Cause I,
I dunno,
I don't think since Carnegie Hall,
there's been a couple of places that you play and you're just like,
um,
I shouldn't be here.
That's what you're thinking.
Just looking at how beautiful it is and then seeing like when you walk to the
dressing room,
you can't help but look at the photos and I'm looking like everyone from Freddie
Mercury,
David Bowie,
Frank Sinatra
in like 1963,
evidently the fucking Beatles and the rolling stones played there on the same
bill,
you know,
and then I'm walking out there going like,
hey,
you know what the fuck's up with chairs and you just,
you know,
your actress,
it just shrinks down either.
I was kind of the thing you had to like fight off.
But,
um,
my agent asked me like,
after the show,
he goes,
so what venue do you want to play next tier in London?
I was like,
ah,
this one,
you know,
what the fuck do you go from here?
Um,
and they're all like,
well,
you know,
it's like booked three years out.
I'm like,
I don't give a shit.
I don't care,
you know?
Um,
unbelievable.
So thank you so much to everybody,
you know,
who came out to the show and afterwards I was able to uh,
run out there and say hello to some people,
signed some posters and uh,
I appreciate the people that hung out and were patient because like I said,
I had a lot of family and friends back there.
You know,
it was sort of my pre birthday celebration.
They had a cake and shit like that,
so I had to do that and I ran out there.
So you got tired of waiting for me.
You left.
I apologize.
But uh,
for the record I did come out,
um,
and the people there were just like ridiculously nice and you know,
there's all these people that had like,
I had like two or three people from Poland go and you got to do a shell in
Poland.
Um,
somebody from Romania,
somebody from Jordan.
When I was in Dublin,
I did a show.
There was this dude from Hong Kong told me he flew in because he saw a clip of
me on Conan O'brien.
How fucking crazy as the internet,
that's is some guy in Hong Kong watching clips of the Conan O'brien show and
then he sees me as a guest,
Colin and makes me look good is always,
and now he wants to come to my show.
He w he goes,
I got tickets for the Dublin show and the London show and he was there by
himself.
I was just like,
all right,
this guy's either going to stab me or this is one of the coolest people I've
ever met in my life.
Fortunately it was the latter.
So,
um,
anyways,
now I'm on vacation.
I'm on vacation.
Do you guys realize the next part,
this is my last podcast in my forties,
man.
Oh,
fucking Billy.
Over the hell.
Where do do do two,
two,
um,
200 and fucking 50 on Sunday,
Sunday,
Sunday.
Um,
actually feel good.
You know,
I don't,
I'm not going to fill any fucking different,
I don't think between now and Sunday,
other than when somebody says,
how old are you?
I don't say for,
I say fear now.
50.
Um,
that's it.
Oh,
Billy.
Billy red nuts is 50 fucking years old,
but whatever thunk it.
Um,
so anyways,
so then we ended up hanging out.
We went out to a bar afterwards,
only had a couple of drinks,
smoke that unbelievable cigar.
And,
um,
then there was like this little casino thing that we went to.
Um,
me and my manager,
my agent and my lovely wife,
um,
ordered some dim sum at like fucking two in the morning and we watched a game
for the NBA finals.
Uh,
which was a great game once again,
but it's just golden state has too many fucking too many people,
man.
It's like,
yeah,
I dunno.
I guess it's genius that the Nva let's these teams
become what they are,
I guess with all of fucking everybody piling on because then guys like me,
I just watch rooting against that team.
Um,
but um,
you know,
it's kind of boring though,
the last two years,
again,
VA kind of knowing at the beginning of the season,
well,
yeah,
obviously these guys are going to win it.
Yeah.
And then they do,
I mean,
this is not even like,
I dunno,
remember that.
Do you remember that?
You know what?
I couldn't get into,
I couldn't get into the Dream Team when we went to the Olympics and they would
Dunkin on Ethiopians and shit.
It was just like,
it's like this is,
it was the most boring fucking,
and they always talk about that team.
Well that was the way it is.
Assemblage of talent in basketball history.
Yeah.
Going up against probably the weakest.
I would rather watch the Globetrotters play the fucking Washington generals.
They watched the Dream Team pay for play fucking Rwanda or whatever the hell we
were doing that year.
You know what I mean?
But what was good about that was they so kicked the shit out of everybody that
sense then
you know
Europe like raise the bar the way they play now and now some of the best players
in the league or from Europe,
which was unheard of when I was growing up.
So I guess I dunno,
something good will come out of this golden state warrior team
that they'll just be,
I don't know,
all the stars will be on two teams.
They should just take the all star team in the east,
in the West.
Right.
And just,
just have that be the league.
Right.
Or at least just have them go to the NBA finals and then you just get what to
watch.
Everybody try
as opposed to the all star game and nobody pays any defense.
I don't fucking know.
MMM.
So anyways,
uh,
that's it man.
I did Royal Albert Hall.
Okay.
Part of the history of freckles.
It's part of that.
I can't fucking believe it.
Can't believe it.
I was saying that there's somebody,
I say you believe fucking 26 years ago,
you sign up for a stupid fucking open mic and it leads to this.
MMM.
Never.
Never in my wildest dreams would I ever think I would ever sell one ticket in
London,
you know,
or any place in Europe.
Forget about getting to play that place.
So that one,
you know,
there's ones that stay you.
Um,
that's definitely one.
you know,
the nine 11 shelf that will stay with me.
The absurdity of that.
The Vicar Street one that I did
Dublin.
Um,
I had a great one in Oslo,
my first really good show in Europe.
These are all the European ones that stick.
Germany was fun when I was teasing him about Hitler.
I've had so much fucking fun over here.
Um,
I just got to figure out how to do these dates now that I got the Kiddo,
but everybody's over here,
by the way.
My lovely daughter is here.
She's such a riot.
She woke up this morning.
I'm like,
you know,
I stayed out late.
Right.
So
obviously she,
you know,
mia gets her up and everything.
She puts her in the bed,
she's next to me and I have my eyes closed and then she just,
I just,
he looks over at me.
She goes,
hi.
Okay.
I start cracking up and then she left.
And that's,
that's just a,
the greatest way ever to start the date.
Nia,
how much fun was last night?
Oh,
that's great.
That's really great.
Um,
what are we doing today?
We're going to go get some bangers and mash and mushy peas.
Oh yeah,
sure.
Oh,
okay.
You look beautiful.
Nini.
Thank you.
I like your dress.
Um,
so what we're gonna do today,
Hey,
if anybody lives in here,
uh,
lives around London,
if you know a place where they have good food,
uh,
please text me the dim sung.
I,
she was great last night,
but,
uh,
I don't know.
We've been kind of striking out here.
I know there has to be good food here.
There has to be.
Okay.
Everybody has the food network.
There has to be some food in London that's actually seasoned correctly.
Um,
I don't underst I just don't get it,
you know,
I mean,
they got salt and pepper,
but after that it just goes off the rails.
That fucking guy that,
uh,
the hell's kitchen guys from here,
people from here can cook.
Where the fuck are they,
Gordon Ramsay?
Does he get,
Oh,
well,
I don't know if I want to go to his restaurant because you know those celebrity
chefs,
they loan their name to something.
It's hit or miss.
Some of them are involved.
Other room just like how much?
Yeah.
I don't give a shit.
Put My fucking name on it.
Um,
anyways,
so tonight I'm going to try to find a place where I can watch potentially the
Washington capitals when their first Stanley Cup,
the bet in the league since 1974,
God bless them,
have 45th season.
I really want to see a vet.
You can get a cup,
you know.
Um,
I dunno,
but also,
you know,
then the other side is if Vegas comes back,
and every Washington capitol fan just fucking hung their head because they know
if anybody could blow a fucking three one lead.
But I,
I just think this,
this capital's team is different.
I'm not trying to jinx them or anything like that.
I'm just going to fucking,
you know,
I'm not in that stupid sports jinx shit.
Okay.
This fucking team,
like,
you know,
the coaching
that's going on here,
you know,
they saw who the nights were and gay one and they said,
oh,
is that I applied.
Well,
here's our adjustment to it and God dammit,
they've won the next three in a row.
And I really hope I get to find a place where I can watch that game.
Maybe I'll go back down to the casino again.
MMM.
And watch it.
But,
uh,
Oh man,
that reminds me of this time.
I watched a patriots game when I was in Australia at a fucking casino at like
four in the morning.
I think
it was four in the morning the next day.
And I was watching son was four in the morning on Monday in Australia and I was
watching Sunday afternoon football.
It's like a 14 hour.
I think I was watching the one o'clock game or something.
Is it a 14 hour difference?
No,
it's like that's how long the flight is,
is 14 hours.
I can't fucking remember.
It's something ridiculous like that.
MMM.
So anyways,
I don't even know if I have any fucking advertising.
Um,
yeah,
I don't know what to tell Ya.
That's it.
It's actually sunny out here in London.
I was worried that it was going to be all fucking shitty weather.
Oh by the way,
you know,
I ended up being like ridiculous traffic getting to the um,
get into the venue last night cause they were building some new hotel called the
mandarin out here and they had some massive fire like half something like half
the firefighters in
mmm.
In all of London where their fight in the fucking thing.
Thank God.
Like you know,
the hotel wasn't a open yet,
although that wasn't what I was saying in my shelf.
I so upset about the fucking traffic.
I was saying I was wishing was full of people.
Maybe they would've been less traffic on the road.
Oh Bill.
Why would you,
why,
why would you say something like that?
Um,
so that fucking burnt down.
It's probably an insurance job.
You know,
I wonder,
I wonder if I can actually look that up right now on my European Internet,
which is going to have all kinds of shit do they literally had an advertisement
for fucking field hockey over here.
It's like field hockey.
Is that a,
that's a,
that's a sport
like on TV sport.
I know it's a sport they got.
They just got some weird shit over here when it comes to this sports stuff.
You know what?
Let me get some of that fucking signed in,
right?
Uh,
you fucking so and so.
Why Fi
yeah.
Into your room number and to your last name.
Yeah,
yeah.
I went to the casino last night.
They asked for my driver's license.
They want to take like a fucking picture of me,
and I was in such a good mood.
I let them do all of that.
I'm like,
well,
I guess I mean your system now.
They go,
no,
we don't.
We don't,
we don't keep it.
It's like,
yeah,
you do.
You take it a fucking picture of me.
Like where,
where does all of that go?
You know,
I just got a fucking phone call,
a message from American Airlines saying that somebody's got my,
a frequent flyer number and might've been trying to see where I was flying and
blah,
and all of this bullshit.
And it's just like,
so we need you,
uh,
you know,
we need you to call us and blah,
blah,
blah.
It's like,
what the fuck do I get to call you guys for?
Why don't you guys fix your fucking weak ass system?
This isn't on me.
I love,
like when,
when like your information might have been compromised,
you call them up and they tell you what you need to do.
It's like,
no,
you know what you need to do?
Stop putting everything up on fucking computers.
Go back to fucking notebooks and pens.
Yeah.
So far like the paper trail that you leave,
it's really impossible now.
Okay.
That's what fucking kills me about that guy that almost went to jail.
But he sat next to Larry David at the Dodgers game.
It's like there was no record of that guy anywhere paying for parking,
getting a hot dog,
his cell phone.
They couldn't track it to the game.
You know,
he didn't go through some intersection,
whether it was a camera with his dodger hat on going into the fucking
Carlito's way,
Kenyon,
whatever the fucking Dodgers play.
Um,
Carlitos Canyon.
What the hell is it called?
Chavez.
Ravine.
Huh?
I don't know.
Yeah.
Anyways,
what the fuck was I looking up?
Oh,
London fire.
So I'm going to do a bunch of touristy shit,
I think today with my parents.
Hopefully if they're up for it,
you know,
I don't think I've ever seen Buckingham Palace.
I liked that dude who just got married by the way.
I don't know.
There's just something about his face.
You like this.
I,
you know,
you can just see how much he's going to annoy the shit out his wife
accidentally.
Come on,
man for.
Can you fucking just for once the Internet.
Can you work for me?
London Fire Hotel Safari.
Can't verify the identif.
Oh,
continue.
I don't give a shit.
My stuff's already been compromised.
Login.
I did log in.
Please select.
Do you accept the terms that we're going to take all of your shit and then call
you later and say somebody that we don't know.
Got It.
And they're now on the dark web looking at fucking kitty porn.
All right,
you are logged in.
Okay,
wonderful.
London.
So the last time I'm trying this everybody,
London fire.
Yeah.
Bill Burns Burns it up last night at the fucking,
sorry.
Ego just kicked in
the London Fire Brigade.
No,
that's not what I want.
Fire Brigade.
That sounds like a fucking musical
hotel.
Fire
fucking London.
Yeah.
All right.
Here we go.
What do we got here?
Mandarin Oriental.
Huge blaze.
Oh Dude,
look at that fucking thing.
Sorry.
You need flash to play this.
Enable it in your browser out.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Plumes of smoke a.
Look who's here.
Hi.
Huh?
How you doing buddy?
She knows annotating to take him to.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
And totally be out of here so she could do that.
Okay.
You got it.
All right.
Um,
bye.
Okay.
All right.
A total of 36 hotel guests in 250 members of the hotel staff were evacuated.
All there were fucking people in their singer.
Robbie Williams was among them.
Uh,
I dunno who Robbie Williams is.
That sounds like a teen idol.
Even if he's old or she,
right.
The blaze reach or they,
the blaze reached several floors but was quickly extinguished or those
the London Fire Brigade set,
um,
the London fire brigade,
the fire brigade,
not to firefighters,
not the fucking Hook and ladder would've welcomed.
They never do the hook and lateral play anymore in the NFL.
Every one of them.
It always seemed to work back in the day.
That's what I'm saying.
Huh?
It's like,
what,
are you going to watch the NHL hockey with me tonight?
No.
Why not?
You love sports.
You just don't realize it yet.
Oh,
I'm looking for something that had to ask you about,
we hear in your podcast,
Oh,
let me hit pause.
She's going to take her around.
All right.
Um,
yeah.
All right.
Sorry about that.
I'm just planning our damn here.
Billows and bellows.
Robbie Williams 44 describes the drama.
I went on the balcony and looked up and there was just billows and billows of
smoke.
I came back in from the balcony and said,
the hotel's on fire and this guy's a smart fucking so smart guy.
And then the hotel's on fire and there's a lot of smoke.
But I mean,
what else would you say?
He really,
he got the information out.
The hotel's on fire.
I probably would have came back in and we'd be like,
yeah,
what the fuck is that?
I was,
you know,
added all these extra words and then the next thing,
a knock at the door came and there was a bellboy there and they said,
get out.
I like this.
This is very,
who's that playwright that just has really fucking choppy dialogue like that.
Or like when you watch law and order,
you know,
they have to get so much information.
They actually time your lines when you do an episode of that show,
they don't care about emotion that just like say it faster.
All right.
Williams and his wife,
Ida felled 39 ran down and external fire escape to safety.
Oh,
there's a video.
I don't need flash for that.
Oh man,
that's a beautiful hotel.
I thought it was under construction.
Wait a minute.
Wow.
You know what billows and bellows is smoke.
Well,
what started it
all right.
Can't emphasize enough how well the evacuation operation put together now being
moved to a nearby hotel for safety.
Well,
who gives a fuck about you?
Ah,
you can't say that.
This is how it is.
Every Debbie things about everybody,
you know.
Right.
Hotel's on fire,
shaking my head,
lol.
Fuck my life.
Yolo.
And he's a guy.
Just wrote,
hope you work are okay.
Anna subtext.
Uh,
I'd like to comfort you slash maybe turn it into some sort of sexual activity.
Um,
all right.
I think that's a good place to end.
Um,
all right.
Yeah,
that is a good friend of mine out here in London.
Says I am now on vacation and I am going to laze about doing fuck all.
Um,
and then that's it.
And then I come back to La and I'm going to get this fucking hour.
Oh Shit.
Uh,
whipped into shape and maybe do another special,
I don't know.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do in this new landscape of 15 minutes
specials,
hour specials.
Um,
well knows.
I got to figure out what the fucking next movies so I can keep coming over here.
And,
uh,
having an unbelievable time.
Sorry if this podcast wasn't funny,
I'm still kind of floating from what happened last night.
I still cannot believe I got to do that.
Um,
it's just,
yeah,
no words,
speeches.
They actually had me sign the book,
you know,
and they like to you to sign the guestbook at Royal Albert after you did the a
Gig.
And once again,
I can barely move.
I wrote something like that.
Just speechless.
You know,
I,
I don't know what,
I didn't know what to say.
So I just said,
thanks.
Thanks for letting a fucking all shit and deck jobs over here.
Spend an hour and 50 minutes on that stage.
Can't fucking believe it.
Unbelievable.
All right.
That's it.
Enjoy the music and,
uh,
I'll talk to you when I'm in my fifties.
All J.
All right,
here's a couple advertisements here.
Uh,
express VPN.
You know,
with all the news lately about data hacks and breaches,
data hacks and breaches,
sorry,
it's hard for me not to worry about my digital privacy.
Well,
there's an understatement.
No matter what you do online,
your prop,
your mobile carrier,
Internet service provider or tracking it all bastards,
Comcast,
Verizon,
Time Warner,
the list goes on.
These nosy bastards are trying to figure out what you're doing.
Companies like these have a record of every single thing you do.
Every website you visit,
every email you send,
it's ridiculous.
So that's why I decided to take my privacy back by using express VPN.
Is that what I did?
I wasn't aware of that these days.
I don't use the Internet without it.
I hate when they write copy like this.
I totally believe in this.
If this is what they're gonna do.
How about that?
With Express Vpn,
your Internet data is encrypted and your IP address is hidden.
Express VPN costs less than seven bucks a month and it's rated the number one
VPN service by tech radar and dozens of expert reviewers.
Express VPN has easy to use.
APPS that run seamlessly in the background of your computer,
phone and tablet.
Turning on express VPN protection only takes the click.
No matter what you do online,
whether you have something to hide,
ooze or you think you're done,
that you don't express VPN is for you.
Uh,
if you're on unsecure Wifi and wanting to keep hackers and spies from senior
data,
express VPN is for you.
Well then just watch a bunch of slap fights and motorcycle videos with me and
the occasional porn.
And if you don't want providers like Verizon recording your entire online
history and then selling it to the whole world,
express VPN is for you to take back your Internet privacy today and find out how
you can get three months.
Go to express
vpn.com/bird that's express e x p r e s s v p n.com/ [inaudible] for three
months free with a one year package every day you use the Internet without
express VP and you're putting your sensitive information at risk.
Don't pull this off.
Don't put this off.
Sorry.
Protect your online data with express VPN today.
Visit Express vpn.com/ [inaudible] to learn moe.
Woah.
All right,
next one here.
Postmates.
I use these guys as usual.
Your stomach and the rest of your life are at war.
Um,
you need to eat,
but you can't stop what you're doing to deal with it and not the only and the
only things what and the only fast things that deliver are not what you want.
That means you don't want fast food.
Why don't these people realize I'm dumb?
Next,
please mention all the Tok course.
I'm going to mention these introducing Postmates,
the APP that adds a delivery.
Option two,
your favorite restaurants.
Imagine anything you want to eat delivered.
You don't have to drive,
park,
or even set up.
They'll throw it right through the window.
You don't have to talk on a phone to order.
Just draw.
Download the APP in order to 24 hours a day,
365 day,
24 hours a day.
Three 65 Postmates will bring you what you want within the hour.
God,
I need glasses.
You can see your work.
You can see where your food is and track your driver.
It was kind of creepy.
You forgot to get eggs and milk,
no problem.
Craving a tasty burger.
Check looking for the bet,
the perfect bottle of red wine or a summer beer.
Order up.
Postmates is your new longterm munchies booty call.
I went a little sideways for a limited time.
Posts May.
Why don't we kill hooker?
We got you for a limited time.
Postmates is giving you $100 of free delivery credit for your first seven days.
To start your free deliveries,
download the APP today and use the Code Borough B U R R one zero zero that's per
100 that's code borough 100 for $100 of free delivery credit for your first
seven days.
Save the hassle,
man.
Get the food you love fast at Postmates with the code burr 100 all right,
lastly,
but not leastly hymns.
H I m.
S is that hairline slowly starting to move backwards.
What did,
how was this seven years ago?
Any bald spots yet?
Yeah,
all over my head.
How will you feel a year from now if you're,
if it's businesses usual up there?
I asked you,
do you want a bald spot to pop up or do you want to do something about it first,
do you realize how big a vat of whatever the hell this is?
They're gonna have to sell me.
Do you want your hairline to recede or do you want to do something about it
first?
Why do guys turn to weird solutions or do nothing?
What's called fucking being a man.
You,
I don't like how they're insulting me here.
Uh,
when they can turn to medicine and science
for
hymns.com
a one stop shot shop for hair loss.
Skincare,
sexual wellness for men,
thanks to science baldness can be optional.
Hims connects you with real doctors and medical grade solutions to treat hair
loss.
While I was never really a good looking fellow anyway,
so this is like putting mag wheels on a piece of shit.
But if you guys are good looking,
this is a great product.
Well known.
Jen,
a generic equivalents to name brand prescriptions to help you keep your hair.
No snake oil pills or gas station counter supplements.
Prescription solution backed by science.
No waiting room.
No awkward doctor visits.
Save hours by going to four hymns.com answer a few quick questions.
Doctor will review and prescribe you products are shipped directly to your door.
My listeners,
my listeners,
get a trial month of hymns for just $5 today.
Right now while supplies last.
See the website for full details.
This would cost hundreds if you went to the doctor or pharmacy,
go to hims.com/burr that's for him.
Sorry.
F O r h I m s.com/burr for hims.com/ [inaudible] one more time cause I said it
the wrong way for
hymns.com/
[inaudible]
I got sites,
subs right now I did a show in Dublin,
Ireland
and
all the crowds were great,
but I gotta tell you those fucking people in Ireland are the funniest that I
can't even explain.
I swear it was just something about like when I go through Great Britain and
Ireland,
it's like Scotland and Ireland.
They like the knuckleheads that I grew up with and when I go to London,
London is like,
was,
is kind of like all the people that I met when I went to New York that were from
Boston.
So they,
they did move away from where they were from,
but they still brought that thing with them cause people in London are
hilarious.
But I was doing a show Dublin on Monday night at the,
the,
the vicar,
a vicar street theater is something just this awesome venue.
And uh,
anyway,
so it was,
it was on a Monday night and it's a really hard night to try and sell tickets
and these people showed up in force
and I can't even tell you how it,
they,
they will fucking hilarious.
Like I was on stage and there was this thing I was talking about about people
hugging their kids and how that could,
p is a good thing,
but if you do it too much,
you could potentially make a week or so.
I mentioned,
and I'll,
I've been telling this story for like six to eight months and I've been saying
how that,
you know,
my mother wasn't a hug,
hug her and didn't hug us when we were kids.
And people just listen and it's just a small detail that leads to this other
part that I want to talk about.
So I've said that line
uneventfully that's even a fucking word with,
with no,
no issue whatsoever for like six months now I'm in fucking Ireland and I just
throw that line out there like I'm not even thinking about it and say,
yeah,
I said,
you know,
my mother didn't hug me when I was a kid and I'm getting ready to say the next
sentence.
And like 15% of the crowd goes,
aw,
I'm not even doing it the way they did.
It just collectively broke my ball.
It was just such the classic fucking,
it was like that Boston Irish thing that I grew up with distilled to its purest
form with actually real Irish people were
I,
you'd almost have to be that a fucking understand what was behind it.
It was like,
eee.
I opened the emotional door,
just a crack in automatically.
It's just,
they just bust your balls about it.
Like,
Eh,
you're fucking,
you know what I like?
And you think they,
I think we got hugs.
You're freckled can't shut the fuck up and tell the judge I can't even,
it just,
I,
I've been trying to,
I would try to explain it to Nia.
She laughed,
but it's still,
yeah,
you kind of had to be there and then,
you know,
so I laughed at when my fucking trying to get your sympathy.
I'm trying to get through this next part.
You assholes and the whole crowd fucking laughs.
Yeah.
Is the,
when I was growing up,
uh,
you know,
my mother never hugged us.
We didn't come from a family like that.
You know what I mean?
[inaudible] island of no hugs.
I can't,
your blood in me said,
I'll fucking look at them.
That's totally what that was.
Oh,
moms did nagase the fucking,
what are you pitching a box?
You policy for the lot of God.
Let me get through it.
All right.
Did any fucking countries.
I've said that in and nobody says shit and then you
[inaudible] I'll
try it and it will have a drink.
Holy fucking God.
Damn Mary.
Yeah.
So I guess you still have bullying.
[inaudible]
and then like a half hour later,
what I had done when I was over there was I bought a bunch of DVDs with me.
Um,
like just the,
uh,
basically the DVD itself,
this little paper thing.
And I was just handing them out to people cause I'm trying to get them to show
other people,
you know,
when I'm out there so I can keep coming back.
Basically trying to get them to spread the word on my comedy.
And then someone's just like,
well why don't you just put it on Spotify?
You dumb fuck.
And I'm like,
yeah cause I'm old.
Alright.
I feel like I have to bring the hard copy.
So I tell these assholes.
Then I've given them free DVDs at the end of the show and I'm halfway through
that spiel telling them that they're getting a free DVD.
All right.
And I'm in the middle of it and I hate this guy in the back of the cry goes,
Oh fuck off.
I don't even think I even explained what I was doing.
I don't know if I had gotten to the part where they were free.
I don't know what the fuck.
Oh,
it was the fact that I was trying to once again go to a nice place where,
hey,
you know,
I really appreciate you guys coming out.
It's really means a lot to me and I want to keep coming back here cause I think
you've got a great comp country or whatever.
And I just,
just opening the door that much.
Oh fuck off.
So I finally just looked and I went,
Jesus Christ,
they're already left.
And I was like,
you know what?
I've played in 20,
almost 22 years as a comedian.
I've played in front of some miserable motherfuckers,
but you guys,
and they were already laughing,
are the most miserable fucking cons I've ever been in.
And they loved it,
absolutely loved it.
And,
um,
it killed me that I couldn't go out drinking with the crowd because I had a
fucking go a head,
an early flight.
Of course,
all the way over to Helsinki.
Totally.
Tonight.
Like I did,
I did,
brought a bunch of DVDs and everything.
They're complimentary.
If you guys coming up
Nice Brown,
you said fuck off.
You don't want them.
You don't have to take one
dude.
I gotta tell you I've been to some miserable fucking places.
This is one of the most
miserable.
Like just,
Hey,
I've got some DVDs that complimentary fuck off.
Don't you just,
you sounded like I drove into the back of your car and I'll fire you want like
get the fuck off.
Fix My pocket car,
giving you a Goddamn show.
[inaudible] a Guy
[inaudible]
I did the Kilkenny festival and uh,
Kilkenny Ireland and that one,
I don't remember Manet's on fries as much as I remember how many pints of
Guinness I drank and this,
oh,
we got hammered and this great laugh than I had with dom.
I rera,
me and Tom were like,
we were just like,
we were like cliff and Norman shares it,
just walking around that city and everybody else would go to bed and we would
still be like carousing.
Right.
So one night we're walking up,
it's like fucking at probably two in the morning on like a Sunday night.
So,
you know,
sleepy town,
everybody's asleep.
We're walking up these cobblestones in the fucking moonlight.
Alright.
Like werewolves in London,
Shit.
It had rained so they like the moonlight was glistening and we're walking up and
it's fucking quiet as Helen were drunk and were laughing.
But try not to,
you know,
wait for somebody to throw up in the shutters.
Yeah.
Hi Joe.
Hi Kate.
My [inaudible] here.
Right.
And we were walking up the thing and we're trying to find a bar that's still
open and all of a sudden we just heard these,
these,
you know,
these Irish singers.
Okay.
What time was this?
This was like two in the morning on a Sunday night.
So we just start following the sound of them singing.
Come up please.
Cobblestones.
And then it sounds like the beginning of a great movie,
right?
Came up and we come down,
we see the light on this bar and we come walking in.
By the time we get in,
um,
you know,
this guy was singing with two other people and they had gone up to the bar.
So it was only one guy singing when we came walking in and we come walking in
and it's just a bunch of townies sitting there way more seats than people.
A little empty,
but a small place.
And this guy's on stage just singing.
I got myself a shady at Haiti,
Haiti,
who seeing in this fucking thing,
right?
And we're taking the bar and we look and there's this guy sitting right in front
of the stage and dude,
he was passed out at a level.
You'd never get this drunk and an American bar.
They'd send you home.
Dude,
this guy,
he looks scared.
This guy was completely passed.
I'll never forget,
he had one arm was slung over the back of the chair and then his head was just
hanging straight down.
When you stood behind him,
he couldn't see his head.
You just saw it like is that this is next.
So the back of his neck,
he was just sitting there,
hang in there,
it looked like he had gotten shot and we walked in and nobody was really
talking.
And this guy's slumped over and all we hear is that.
And everybody turns around and looks at us.
And meanwhile that guy's in the background going,
ah,
green alligator and a long neck or whatever.
And he fucking Ah,
look at each other.
And it was like one of those things where we now we can't leave.
So we are,
we walk up to the bar and they asked,
you know,
really thick Irish brogue what we wanted,
ordered a couple of Guinnesses.
And I'm sitting there trying to hold it together cause I know I can't look at
dom and I'm hearing dom starting to laugh and this guy still second and dom
starts,
dom starts riffing,
he starts riffing lyrics to what?
This guy singing.
And he's just in my ear going,
I got my shelf of totality and he's doing this thing and do,
we started,
we started fucking laughing and we couldn't stop like to school goes.
And the whole thing was what was keeping it going was if there's tension like in
like in high school or middle school when the teacher goes to the next person
who left,
yeah.
Gets fucking detention.
Like that tension makes you,
you can't stop fucking on.
Oh yeah.
So we knew they were looking at us and I'm getting nervous.
Like I,
they think we're laughing at their country and all this.
So I'm trying to be polite and not laughing all it just,
it just,
dude,
it was just fucking wave of laughing.
I remember,
I've never seen dom like I was looking at,
he literally like his mouth was open and he had tears.
What?
And then what was cracking me up was it looked like almost like he was crying
and that what that guy was singing was making me cry.
So then there was another wave of laughs,
oh my God,
the guy's just slunched over.
And the whole time.
And then like the bartender would look at me like,
what the fuck are you laughing at?
And I would look over,
look away,
and all I could look at with this guy slumped over is this guy on stage.
And he was singing,
he had his eyebrows up and he was hitting these fucking high notes until it was,
it was torture.
But it was a great laugh.
But it was that whole thing probably took all of four minutes.
But like Mike,
Mike,
oh,
my stomach was fucking killing me.
Oh my God.
I would have loved to see that.
I would have loved to somewhere in those adventures
I picked up.
Oh,
that's a great story.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burns the Monday morning podcast,
but June 7th,
2010 how the hell are ya?
What's going?
Are you better?
MMM.
Jesus Christ.
I can't get away from that fucking oil spill.
You know,
try to go out to a bar.
You try to drink your troubles away.
And every time I look up,
there's some fucking burger getting picked
up by scientists.
You know,
I like that when,
you know,
when they pick up the bird,
they still have to make sure that the bird doesn't like fucking bite.
The shit out of him still was picking up a Pelican,
you know?
And he's got his,
he's got his gardener glove and he's holding the beak shut his fucking stupid
animals.
It's like,
dude,
I'm trying to help you,
you know,
can't help you if you don't want help.
You know,
you dumb fuck,
look at me.
I wanted to eat you.
Would I be gingerly picking you up?
Why you trying to bite me?
That shit you're covered in his oil.
Alright.
You dumb fuck if you weren't such a stupid bird,
you,
you understand the gas combustion engine,
you know?
Um,
anyways,
whatever.
Blaming the victim here is fucking unreal,
man.
Can they just kept that shit?
All right.
You know,
hug Dama my dual credit can,
I just can't,
they just put a top on it,
you know,
for the first time I actually looked at the spill.
There's certain things that I just can't watch.
The second I heard what was going on down there.
It's like I'm not gonna Watch that shit because I have absolutely no power to,
to stop it.
All I can do is just sit there watching it going,
fuck,
you know,
whatever.
What are you gonna do?
What do you,
what,
what the fuck?
How the fuck do you stop it
once the loo,
I'm,
I'm Kinda handicapped this week.
People as I had a crazy fucking weekend and,
uh,
my broad is still sleeping in the other room,
so I'm,
this is going to be one of those,
a medium energy podcasts of fuck you all right.
Fuck you.
Whoever.
Just side who have just rolled your fucking eyes,
right?
You don't have a medium energy day where you don't put in the fucking effort.
You know,
like what's his face that power forward for the fucking Lakers,
who's full of gummy bears?
Every other fucking game is sugar crashes and he's not worth a shit.
Are we sick?
His name is,
uh,
not Lamar Odom.
I always think it's Riley Odom who I believe was a guy who played for the
fucking Broncos,
Riley ODMs.
And
the seventies or was it haven Moses?
I Dunno.
I Dunno where these names come through,
but I'm sick.
You know everybody fucking talking about the Goddamn oil spill.
You know,
acting like human beings are the fucking worst.
We're down there.
We're trying to help these filthy animals in,
in,
in the effort to help them this,
they're still attacking us.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like,
dude,
I can't help you.
You know,
you have to want help.
Okay.
You gotta you gotta want to change.
You got to want to come out of the Muck,
dude.
All right.
Yeah.
I've got to fucking pull you out of the sludge and cover your mouth at the same
fucking time.
What it was this,
some sort of Jujitsu,
some animal Jujitsu.
Oh,
Jesus.
Morning Sweetheart.
What was with little deer?
Okay.
You know,
some days when your significant other walks by,
you just know this is one of these days.
You know,
those couple of points that I want to make in the relationship.
I'll wait till tomorrow to try to make those points.
Wow.
Whew.
Jesus Christ.
She looked like a fucking future hall of fame quarterback in the twilight of her
career in the morning.
You know,
that's how she,
when she walked by Jesus Christ,
that was such a great fucking reference.
And I butchered it.
She looked like a future hall of Famer in the twilight.
I th I think I did it backwards.
What if you pull a pit bull's tail?
You liked that Cleo.
You're like,
I don't pull it.
I just hold onto it.
All right.
Get out of my face.
So I'll get you,
you're not covered in oil.
Would you try to bite me if I pulled you out?
You wouldn't,
you'd be sitting there going,
whoa.
All right.
So anyways,
um,
speaking of the Lakers and Celtics,
this is just,
just in fucking insane time of the year with the NBA finals and the Nhl finals
are on at the same time,
you know,
and women just go crazy because they are loving it.
They're loving every second of the sports.
My girl watches every fucking TV show then involves,
let's take the dumbest content from the stupidest state and uh,
just start documenting their family.
You know,
and then that then the people start ramping up the stupid because the cameras
are on.
I went in there,
she was watching something.
They had just a bunch of dumb skanks from Jersey planning a fucking wedding in
rather than addressing the real issue,
which is that these people are gonna fucking procreate.
They're actually dealing with this little shit about,
oh my God,
I want wear chef fine.
And all my skanky bridesmaids,
you know,
with their scraped out uteruses from all those abortions have to wear the same
fucking color.
I mean that's television people.
I don't think it is.
It's not television.
How do we go from Lawrence Welk to that number?
When we had family values,
Lawrence Welk had so many morals.
It was actually creepy.
I ban and the two and
go on Youtube and go look up the Lawrence Welk show.
There was a dance team on there,
Bobby and Susie or something.
Just the widest,
purest.
Um,
let's go spoon with Jesus.
Fucking white names you could ever come up with.
And they used to do these fees to fucking dance these stupid smiles on their
face.
And it was just that classic little skippy.
Do skip the do all across the fucking,
the fucking stupid dance floor,
you know?
You know they both had fucking eating disorders as goddamn dancers.
You got to have the body of a fucking seventh grade or your entire life.
It's like you're 35 years old.
What do you eat?
Huh?
Fucking handful of cottage cheese before you go out the Goddamn door,
Cleo,
get out.
Get away from me.
Come on.
You're sniffing up my feet.
I'm trying to focus here.
Dogs are so fucking emotional.
Look at that.
Look on your face.
You really just had a sad look on your face.
Now you're making me feel bad.
Hmm.
Anyways,
I'm talking about the Lawrence Welk show.
I go,
look,
Dad,
shut up.
It was just the admin system.
It was fucking horrible.
Some of those shows back then.
You know,
that's,
that's kind of like what I grew up on.
Ya know,
I just saw those shows and I sat down and watched it for the longest time.
That was like music to me,
you know,
and I asked for,
uh,
I want to record,
I want to,
I wanted some music for my birthday.
I don't even know what,
I didn't know what it was.
I just wanted to record,
give me a record in the first record I was given was a sing along with Mitch and
the gang was a Mitch Miller record.
You know,
I always wonder why it never got laid in high school.
But you know when,
when you're,
when you're weaned on roll out the barrel,
oh he's,
other kids are singing like fucking Aerosmith and led Zeppelin and I'm like,
won't you come Home Bill Bailey,
won't you come home?
You love up.
Whoa.
You know what kind of kid in the third grade wants to play the Banjo?
I didn't know any better.
I didn't know that there was electric guitar.
I actually liked it.
Tuba fucking Mickey Finn.
Huh?
The fucking something.
Or Robert E.
Lee.
That was like one of my favorite song.
Ted Heath Orchestra Elks parade.
Those who might jams.
I used to sit there and you know,
normal kids would sit there and listen to like some fucking,
you know,
classic rock and then fantasize about being able to play it first of all the
fucking hot broads in their 14th,
fifth,
fourth grade class,
you know,
normal fantasies.
I was actually thinking about playing the trumpet Solo on one o'clock.
Jump.
Yeah.
That'll get on bill that we'll have them all lined up,
you know,
the extra saliva miles with their fucking braces.
I always loved that when kids get braces.
I lucked out.
I never had to have braces.
The kids had braces in like the give body thinking it's food for the first
fucking two weeks trying to break it down.
[inaudible] he kept hearing effectful um,
ugh.
Fucking elastic bands.
What are these fucking pussy kids have nowadays where they got that?
He got that clear channel Shit they put in there.
Whatever the fuck it is.
The clear I was at the fucking stuff the athletes take.
Um,
I had a fucking,
what the fuck is he?
You know that,
that shit where
it's just a plastic mouth guard.
You put it in your mouth and you don't have to go through the torture.
The kids,
you know,
from my grade had to go through this is like really,
that's like old school standup material.
You know,
having to go there and get your fucking braces tightened in our right now might
make my,
my uh,
my Mike,
Mike,
Mike.
I might,
I might.
Computer screen went to um,
the save mode and what it does is it,
it,
it puts up all the albums that I've downloaded onto my douchey fucking iPod,
which sucks,
which breaks every six months or needs to be updated because he can't handle the
new technology.
I haven't,
no,
I have a nice mix of music here.
Gordon Lightfoot.
Oh,
this is some easy listening shit.
Sting God smack.
Let me try to get some credibility.
Houses of the holy,
one of the worst led Zepplin albums ever except for two songs.
The rain song and fucking no quarter.
The crunch is,
I am going to elect is one of the worst songs ever written by a great band.
MMM.
Oh,
Stevie wonder,
what does that one songs in the key of a odd is a Jay z one.
I don't know why I have that.
Which one is that one?
Is that the one where he was going to retire but then he didn't lamb of God the
Romantics.
Remember that one?
What I like about you,
when they had the red suits on red leather suits and there was nothing wrong
with it.
Um,
that one with Justin Timberlake steps on the crystal ball,
the disco ball,
cause he was bringing sexy back.
Remember that when?
Wham,
wham,
um,
Neil young harvest moon,
Merle Travis,
look at me.
I'm all over the fucking map.
1950s hits and highlights the nerves.
Any this best of brick Jeff Beck truth that album.
Huh?
Remember that one that had half a led Zeppelin one
Jacko Pistorious
audio slate.
It's a super group.
Okay,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
I started to talk about Lakers,
Celtics,
and a,
I'm going to extend an olive branch right now.
And rather than,
than doing the usual and going off and that type of shit,
I want,
I want to,
you know,
and I'm even gonna drag in the hockey fans too.
I want to talk right now to fans or the Celtics,
the Lakers,
the Blackhawks and the flyers because,
uh,
I got a question because I'm having a fucking heart attack.
I'm aging like seven years,
which eat with each point that is scored or not scored in the Celtics Lakers
series and a,
I got to ask you,
you big sports fans out there.
Why do we give a fuck?
You know what?
It's fucking,
it's stupid.
I get it.
I get,
I mean,
you know you this,
I give a fuck so much that I'm actually jealous of people who don't give a shit.
Like last night after I watched the game,
like,
you know,
I felt like I got,
I got acquitted or something.
Like that's the level of stress.
I'm just sitting there,
you know,
like fucking r Kelly thinking there's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Holy Shit.
They had video.
It looks just like you.
I know,
but it's not me.
You know,
all those years would be offended when everybody says we all look alike.
Now I'm saying we all look alike because I peed on a 12 year old amongst other
things.
Alright,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
why don't we give a fuck to that.
Like I'm sitting here like this is,
this is how much I give a shit.
I know you guys are going to think this is nuts.
I actually had an opportunity,
some eat the last second had a ticket to the game.
It's a 20 minute fucking ride down the street and I turned it down.
I turned it down because I,
first of all,
I already went to an NBA finals game.
I already went.
Okay.
So I checked that off the bucket list.
I went to the Lakers,
Celtics actually lost Lakers,
Celtics final,
you don't if you're going to go to a final game,
that's the great thing.
And I went into enemy territory with my fucking Celtic shirt on and I basically
paid like 400 bucks or whatever the fuck to sit in the last row of the staple
center to every five seconds to have somebody go sale takes our beaches.
You know,
it's like I paid to get verbally fucking abused and to not hear the commentating
and all that type of shit,
but it was still awesome to be there.
But,
um,
I,
I give a fuck too much.
I want to hear the Goddamn game.
I don't want to sit there and have to look around fat fucks and drunks getting
up to get their goddamn beer and listen to their stupid shit.
I don't,
it's not worth,
I'm paying money to be tortured.
I don't want to do it.
So I actually stayed in my living room
and I watched the game on mute.
I can't even listen to the fucking announcers cause they drive me nuts.
And half of it is because sometimes they say dumb shit.
And the other half is because I'm so psychotically into my team that I am
convinced that everyone in the booth hates my team,
secretly hates my fucking team.
I actually have a debate with Paul Versey comedian,
right due to opens up from me.
You people in New York on the east coast,
you've seen them don't act like you haven't.
Um,
or even down in Atlanta.
Oh yeah,
the dude,
Hey,
I don't name names,
he may or may not have been the guy I went to fucking the master's with and bet
on the turtles.
But anyways,
um,
he's convinced that Tim McCarver hates the fucking Yankees and I'm like,
dude,
he hates the fucking red sox.
And then we just kind of came to a conclusion that,
uh,
you know,
it's kind of in our head and also the Tim McCarver might kind of be a Douche a
little bit.
I think he likes the cardinals because that's who he played for.
But whatever,
I'm getting off track.
Like,
don't you wish you ever wish,
like sometimes you didn't give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
Like after I did my show and went down.
I mean,
actually after I watched the Lakers game,
I went down the street and uh,
I did stand up and a,
I came walking in and I was talking to some dude who was from New Hampshire.
So my God Celtics,
right?
He's like,
yeah,
yeah.
He goes,
they win tonight.
And I'm like,
you fucking Dick.
You fucking,
yeah,
they won.
Yeah,
they want.
Okay.
So now you get to have the joy that they won and you didn't have to go through
the fucking cardiac arrest that I went through.
Oh,
it's unreal.
When the Lakers start coming back,
I got to walk out of the fucking room.
Literally,
I walk out of the room,
come back in,
I peek,
peek back into the fuck am I can't fucking take it.
It's like the oil spill.
This like this fucking thing that I want to turn out.
Right?
And,
and it isn't,
and there's nothing I can fucking do about it.
I'm just sitting there fucking helpless,
you know?
I don't know what I gotta do,
do I got,
I got going to be on like a fucking stair master like some broad while I watch
it to get that extra energy out.
I fucking like every like seven minutes.
I'll take the mute button off and I can listen to a sentence and a half before
van Gundy or somebody else.
All these,
these fucking guys who played the game,
coached the game,
know way more about the game and I am immediately convinced that they don't know
what the fuck they're talking about.
And I start yelling at my TV like a goddamn maniac.
Okay,
I'll tell you what else fucking sucks.
That's right.
I'm on a roll here about shit that sucks fucking,
I lived in New York like the,
I'm so fucking sick of living in this city that is the arch rival of that,
of one of my teams,
you know,
and all day long I got to look at these fucking Laker flags flapping off the
side of the cars.
You know those things.
A Gay,
by the way,
you drive down the streets with your food,
Uy
with your fucking team flags in the window and seeing those little clip on
things.
Actually,
I see them and I start,
I start getting angry.
You know what I mean?
Like it's a fucking al Qaeda flag.
Did they have a flag?
You know,
what is,
what is it of them are sneaking into a pizza parlor,
crouching in a cave
fucking punks.
Um,
I just,
I,
I see them and I just want to fucking,
you know,
I dunno for some reason,
like,
like wire cutters.
I don't know why you'd need wire cutters to cut a plastic poor excuse for a
flagpole.
I just want to snip them off.
W what?
W really bill,
you take it to that level.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I do.
I don't do it,
but like,
I want to,
I would have gone to that Laker game,
uh,
yesterday and I would've fantasized about beating the shit out of everybody in
my row,
you know,
and the Celtics winning by 40.
It's not unhealthy.
It's not fucking health.
He looked at my leg,
my legs fucking shaking right now.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing here.
So yeah.
So basically I lived,
I lived in New York during the height of the curse of the baby.
Every time I wanted to go see the red sox,
I had to sit and fucking Yankee stadium had people go 19 eight Jane,
you know,
and I got that Catholic fucking,
punish me shit.
So I'd show up with my red sox shit on,
you know,
and at that point we hadn't won in [inaudible] 86 years.
So all I could do was just personally attack the looks of the person,
you know,
make fun out of their hat,
looks stupid on their head or some shit like that.
And they,
they would be like,
what is your have to do with championships?
Nothing.
You fucking idiot.
We haven't won in 86 years.
I got nothing here.
All you can talk about is how you,
how,
how neatly your man tit sit on your fucking your beer belly.
Fine.
I don't know.
So then whatever the red sox finally went in,
I can breathe.
You know,
what song is that?
I can breathe again.
Can Pre the good one of those fucking 80 songs he thought really meant something
down and down and down and down and down
the fuck was it?
I was a lot of reverb.
Reverb makes up for a lot.
That's like the poor man's fucking autotune.
Um,
anyways,
fuck.
Am I talking about here?
Yes.
So then that shit ends,
you know,
Celtics,
a dead in the fucking water.
Then I the technically not even a fucking NBA team.
When,
when I make the decision to move out here and I move out here,
you don't want the most underhanded deals in the history of sport.
Kevin Mchale somehow decide,
we'll give you our best player for nobody.
Give it back to our form of fucking team that I used to play for.
And next thing you know where this shit,
and then I guy sale takes our BHS and I listened to that fucking these fucking
flags.
I hate it.
Why can't this business being like,
you know,
Oregon,
this is how much I fucking hate.
Like I'm sitting here watching the game,
right?
And all of a sudden I see Hillary Swank,
you know,
court side,
the worst court side and all the fucking basketball is the fucking Lakers.
Jesus Christ,
those people with their fucking laminated faces.
This is how fucking fucked up people are out here in la.
They get plastic surgery in their twenties
it's like you out of your mind you,
that's the take a picture of yourself,
your 20s when you get to your 50s then hand them the picture and be like,
I want to look like that.
You know,
give him something to work off of.
Give these guys 30 years to fuck up other people's faces before they get to
yours.
Jesus Christ.
You know,
stop eating fried food.
Get on a fucking treadmill.
What's wrong with you?
Right?
I'm telling you for coming,
you know,
games six,
like I'm going to be like,
yeah,
if it,
if there is a good six,
this is going to be a game six.
This is going to be a torturous fucking series.
Um,
I am worried about the Celtics.
Garnette is heart and Paul Pearson hurt then fucking,
uh,
the van Gundy's go on their car nuts only gone up with one hand.
That's all I heard.
Well,
you got to use two hands for a rebound.
I hit fucking mute.
I'm like,
you think he doesn't fucking know that?
Then my buddy Paul verse,
he calls up,
he goes,
dude,
I think Arnett's heart,
he kept rubbing his shoulder,
right?
And then all of a sudden my buddy called me today.
He goes,
yeah,
they're saying that on the radio.
He fucked up his shoulder.
See,
that's why I don't listen.
Put It on fucking mute.
You know,
I don't,
I don't like how f just all these fucking people will now act like,
like the same way the Lakers won the first game,
then all of a sudden the other Celtics fucking fished.
Right.
And now the Celtics one out those,
the Lakers fucking [inaudible],
they play two games.
It's one one.
It's a great fucking series so far.
Okay.
It's the usual fucking thing.
They always got to act like whatever just happened.
His law for the rest of the rest of fucking time.
I can't,
I it,
it drives me fucking nuts.
But I gotta tell you this dude,
oh a I owe Pau Gasol and apology.
All right.
Now I'm not going to be a deck here and be like,
well,
you know,
Garnette is in fucking 100% whatever.
That guy's going strong to the fucking hoop.
He is not the guy he was a two fucking years ago.
That guy's playing fucking great.
That's fucking baseline.
Reverse Jamey had was the shit was the shit.
You see this,
this is a Celtics fan given pau Gasol props in the middle of the fucking series.
And I wish more you fucking sport cunts could act like that instead of fucking,
you know,
latch and you're hitching of the trailer of your loser life up to your fucking
team to the point.
So you get so into it that you can't even,
you can't even appreciate it.
Oh,
a fucking good play.
You know,
he's fucking red sox fans.
Fucked.
Ever cheat of really,
really
fucking stupid.
You know,
guys,
the Shit fucking,
you know,
one of the best players I've ever fucking seen.
You know,
the way he handles his shit on and off,
you know,
do I want the guy who went,
fuck no,
but am I going to sit here like an asshole?
You know,
and act like this dude isn't a great player or that fucking reverse jam.
Pau Gasol head was the shit.
I want to know how pau Gasol became a Laker.
He's a fucked up looking white dude.
If that doesn't say Celtic,
I don't know what does,
and this is really like the classic Celtics Lakers series where they've always
been just,
you know,
faster,
always had more talent.
And we've always just been,
you know,
like,
this is fucking,
you know,
fucking fucked up.
Look untamed.
But somehow we win.
How many good looking Celtics have their bed?
I mean this
Larry Bird,
Dennis Johnson,
Kevin Mchale,
I guess had dreamy eyes if you're just focused on that,
but the rest of his body,
good Lord.
He looks like his fucking arms are so God damn long.
He looks like he would walk like that thing in the and,
and uh,
what was that movie with the CIC?
Crawled up out of the,
well,
was that the movie?
Oh is it that other movie that the,
the uh,
oh Jesus Christ.
One of those Japanese horror movies with that fucking thing crawls and as it
moves its hands,
its back legs would step over its front fucking legs.
Like some sort of mutant crab.
I Dunno,
I don't fucking know Kendrick Perkins.
Okay.
I saw Kendrick Perkins,
by the way,
a lobby of this hotel about a week ago.
That guy is a fucking mountain of a man.
He's a fucking mountain,
you know,
and to think that he looks like medium size next to Shaq,
these fucking people that ain't know.
If you ever get down on yourself that you never made,
you never made it to the professional ever stand next to a professional athlete
and just realize that it was game over by third grade when there's people
walking around with that sort of fucking bionic DNA.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
I can't believe I was allowed to go to gym class.
Pass the fucking sixth grade,
my pasty fucking Forrest Gump legs.
Um,
anyways,
so let's get back to this shit man.
White of why,
you know,
maybe,
maybe you guys can just answer me that.
Why the fuck do we care so much?
Like right now,
you know who's getting their,
their Goddamn fucking heart's ripped out and our aging other fans of the
Blackhawks in the flyers.
All right,
this,
this is one of these great series where somebody is finally going to have that
Advil lifted off their chest.
Blackhawks have in one sense,
61 the flyers have in one sense,
75.
Okay.
75 isn't as bad as 61,
but you know what the fuck.
You know,
I was writing on my Facebook page.
We pulled out of Vietnam in 1975.
All right.
There was only one kind of cheerios in 1975.
You understand,
we get it done.
Why am I putting
this in historical perspective here and can I dumb it down?
The Rubik's cube was still about six,
seven years away.
People the last time the flyers wanted.
Okay,
love you.
You just got to fucking dumb everything down.
Um,
friend of mine who actually runs the,
uh,
the mm podcast page,
the uh,
the fan page,
the official and only fan page of the Monday morning podcast,
um,
who he gets exclusive,
uh,
whatever.
You know what I do is I do the podcast now cause I want to,
I want to take this podcast and next level is what I do is I do the podcast then
.
Aye.
You know,
I upload it and I sent it to the dude who runs that page and he puts all the
fucking,
you know,
all the references up,
all the youtube videos and everything.
Then we try to sync it where we,
we both fucking put it on at the same time,
you know,
taking it to the next level.
Totally lost.
Just lost my fucking train of thought here.
Um,
oh,
that's right.
He sent me this article.
This is the classic just dumbing down just pussy way that we're running this
country right now.
These dis p people actually I guess the,
uh,
the nationwide,
the national spelling bee is coming up,
you know,
and everybody laughs at these,
these kids who go up there,
they're right at their fucking awkward years.
You know what I mean?
Where they have the nose of the adult and like the fucking teeth of a fucking
two year old,
you know,
12 year old.
So,
um,
they have in the national spelling bee in Washington DC,
they celebrate these,
uh,
these brainiac fucking kids that eventually will work for a corporation.
And without really knowing it will probably work on some device that'll Sunday
kill millions of people,
you know,
in other words,
the future.
So there's people actually they're picketing the spelling bee.
All right.
I had to,
I had to fucking read this to actually believe it.
Okay.
It says not all spellers headed for Washington DC for the National Spelling Bee
spelling bee on June 1st through the third think English spelling is a good
thing that should be celebrated with spectators and judges inside the Grand
Hyatt Hotel,
uh,
while,
while spectators and judges inside the Grand Hyatt Hotel will be pondering the
spellings of obscure words and admiring the efforts of contestants outside on
the street.
Some members of
the American Literacy Council and These Simplified Spelling Society,
Aka the SSS.
We'll be trying to convince Passerbuys that the English spelling is a problem
that needs fixing.
Why are people so fucking dumb?
Okay.
Now that's something.
If you want to get support,
simplified spelling society,
you don't go to the fucking nationwide spelling bee with the kids.
Just learned,
okay,
how to spell fucking rheumatoid arthritis or whatever the fuck going to ask
them.
Have you used it in a sentence?
Your grandmother has rheumatoid arthritis.
Okay.
That was me.
Tell rheumatoid arthritis.
Isn't that two words?
Um,
why don't you just go to a bar?
Yeah.
You want to get names on that fucking petition.
That's who you're doing it for.
The dumb fucks.
This is the point these people have it said like those in size side.
They may admire the efforts of the contestants,
but they will have signs in sandwich boards with slogans such as I'm through
with,
through.
Okay.
In other words,
I'm through with,
through and enough is enough spelled e,
and enough is too much spelled e.
Their aim is to alert parents,
educators,
politicians,
business people,
and others concerned about the unacceptable level of illiteracy,
illiteracy among English speakers to the fact that a prime cause for this is
English spelling.
Do you get it?
The reason why there's such a high level of illiteracy is not because we
constantly cut funding to the public schools,
not because spelling is something that's even fucking stressed by most people
anymore.
It's because the words are too difficult to spell.
One of the pickers pickers,
one of the picketers.
This is hilarious and I can't even fucking read.
I'm part of the problem.
I might sign these people's petition.
Um,
one of the picketers at the ALC chair in the SSS member Allen Mole from Boulder,
Colorado,
put it this way,
are odd spelling retains words like cough Bo through and though this increases
illiteracy and crime fix it and you fix a host of problems,
we want to fix it to this guy is basically saying that the reason why
there's serial killers,
there's people holding up fucking Mcdonald's,
there's purse snatchers
and all this type of shit is because cat is not spelled with a k.
You know,
I mean on once side.
I fucking respect this guy because he actually has a cause.
He actually got off his couch and said,
you know what?
I'm going to do something about this.
This is the reverse of what I was trying.
Maybe that's why.
Let's get smart America bombed on my podcast.
You know,
you guys are waiting for this sss guy to come in here,
you know,
I mean,
not,
not to be the classic person who goes,
what's going to happen next,
but what is gonna Happen Next?
Two plus two was like four,
five,
three.
You know,
as long as you're within one,
we'll give it to you.
Rounded off to the nearest right answer.
Learn how to fucking spell your lazy fucks.
That's pathetic.
And I also like how to like the illiteracy illiteracy problem is it,
you know,
that's the reason why there's fucking crime.
You know,
La,
I bet those fucking bankers,
you know,
those bankers are literate and they're great at math.
They're graded fucking math where it always works out for them.
The fucking cunts.
They went till fucking Ivy League schools.
What did I do?
Why did I taper off?
I relieve schools.
Ivy League schools.
They went to Ivy League fucking schools.
They went to Brown.
They went to Cornell.
Wentworth.
I Dunno,
that's one for you that,
that did some party fucking,
uh,
you know,
something that's,
what killed it?
What killed it was a,
was cable.
That's the best way.
That's what really made people dumb.
Yeah.
Cable and the Internet.
800 fucking channels.
You know,
people used to back in the day,
they used to load up as something called a station wagon.
All right.
First of all,
everybody had like five fucking kids back in the day.
All right.
Which was a great thing to do.
You know,
cause you know a couple of them are going to be fuck ups.
Okay.
And you can let it go.
You can let it go.
That's why parents who have only one kid are so fucking over protective
protective is because they went all in world series of poker.
They pushed all their chips and this is their one fucking hope.
That kid can't be a fucking serial killer.
You have seven,
eight fucking kids.
You know one of them,
you know
you can handle it.
You can fucking handle it.
If one of them's a phase,
the black sheep,
what are you going to do?
You know,
what the fuck are you going to do?
I mean the guy,
he's a
transvestite and sometimes pyromaniac.
Huh?
Anybody remember that line there?
He met a transvestite and sometimes pyromaniac the greatest line ever uttered on
the fucking a and e channel,
possibly in television history when they were talking about these ds for this
does serial killer tandem,
that's how they described one of the guys.
One of the guys was just killing somebody on his own and then he had to leave
town
because the heat was getting too high and he went to a new town,
hangs out some shady bar and that's where he meets his,
his,
his serial killer partner.
You know,
Kinda like what Bill Gates met that other fucking nerd and they made the first
laptop.
These two serial killers came together
and to describe his partner,
the,
the fucking that Bill Curtis guy goes there.
He met a transvestite in sometimes pyromaniac
back in the day people we had station wagons and there was a whole bunch of
fucking kid.
He didn't have to have a fucking spell and be okay,
you have a spelling bee because you only have one kid and the kid can't compete
against himself.
You've got to go with a bunch of other fucking kids.
Back in the day we had station wagons and they were full of fucking kids.
All right.
And you just did drove somewhere and on the way there,
you know
you listened to Mitch Miller Oh,
[inaudible] room,
right?
And you fucking,
you said Shit like,
um,
do you give,
your parents would quiz,
you were Ivy League schools named the capitals of stuff states,
you know,
that's what the fuck you did.
And you stopped at a rest area and your dad send you in there by yourself.
There was no problem,
there was no worries.
And you walked in there and some guy exposes himself to you in a not a deal with
it.
Yeah,
just you're buried it.
He got back in the fucking car and exceed.
Know you're at a dairy queen,
sort of enjoying the ice cream,
but sorta not.
That's when America was intelligent.
Back when we used to have like five,
six kids and you throw them in a fucking station wagon and then you quizzed him
and as you drove to some poor excuse for a tourist attraction,
you know you go out to go look at fucking while bill Cody's fucking log cabin.
You know your dad be sitting there.
See them with anger,
left arm,
all sunburned from having it hanging out the side fucking window.
The rest of them ghost white.
Now was it spelling tests,
quizzes and dairy queen.
Somewhere along the line it became OMG laughing my fucking ass off all this
abbreviation.
These people want to turn it into that.
Fuck that man up.
You pussies learn how to spell goddamn words.
I did it for a month.
I'm a better speller because it because of it,
because it I'm not,
I've already forgot.
I finally conquered the word restaurant though forever.
I couldn't remember where the you went.
It's rest and then a u.
R.
A.
N.
T.
I couldn't remember if the you came,
which,
which a the you came after.
Is it [inaudible] or restaurant?
Gretar aunt.
It's a restaurant.
These fucking people would spell it.
Reg s.
T r a n t restaurant.
Now know that would still be fucked up.
How do you spell rant?
Douchey.
You know that's restaurant.
How do I spell that?
Phonetically.
R E s t.
S t.
R.
O.
N.
T.
Restaurant.
Let's go to the fucking restaurant.
I look,
I'm getting so worked up like these guys are actually going to succeed.
Um,
you know,
it's like listen to the people down the south when they talk about the South
Gilner Razah Gan.
Is it,
are you going to secede from the union?
How did that work out the first time?
Um,
wow.
Look at me.
What,
what is wrong with me?
All right,
let's get to some youtube videos for the fucking week.
Um,
for the fucking week.
Listen to me with my tough talk.
Um,
all right,
hang on a second.
I've got a couple actually really good a drum videos for you guys to watch.
They're actually hilarious.
Somebody sent me this on my,
uh,
on my Facebook and the name of this video is this drummer search.
This,
this drummer is at the wrong gig
and uh,
it's just a guy where he is fucking it.
This guy is awesome.
He is performing like it's still 1986 and they are opening for like fucking
motley crew and he is trying to blow Tommy Lee off the stage.
That's the way he is performing.
And they are,
they're playing at like just some fucking banquet and everybody else has,
I'm playing at a banquet energy in this mother fucker is just like,
I don't know.
I played drums for fucking years and I,
I would have to slow the video down to try and figure out how the fuck he's
doing.
Some of the shit
he does this move with his both his arms.
He looks like he's in a dryer.
It's the only way to describe it as fucking code is flying around.
And somehow he never misses a beat.
It's fucking awesome.
But it looks absolutely ridiculous yet awesome.
You're just check it out.
All right.
And you can watch all these videos if you don't want to search.
Okay,
I'll make it easy for you.
Just like the SSS people go to the,
uh,
the MM podcast.com and uh,
we'll have all that shit up there for you.
Here's another one.
Korean drummer rocks out.
Um,
this is actually from a long time ago,
but this guy is just fucking,
you know,
it's just what,
what drumming and performing is all about this guy.
He's the shit.
A lot of times people on the drummer,
I'm sitting behind all these drums.
No one's going to look at me.
This fucking guy,
you can't not look at him.
And they got this hot girl singing the song,
you know,
and he's fucking,
he's starts headbanging and these,
I think this,
this guy is like headbanging before people knew how to head bang.
Um,
and is the last thing,
uh,
you can go on youtube and our checkout,
because I tried to download this album,
it's the first Arrow Smith album,
which I haven't listened to I think in about 15 years.
It's such a great album.
It's the one that dream on was initially on.
That's only like the really the real hit off.
And they usually play like Mama Ken and stuff in concert,
but they're there.
They're so fucking,
the album is so like raw and Steven Tyler's voice,
he's,
he sounds so young and he's just,
he's right at the beginning of like a few of like his signature ways of phrasing
and stuff.
And,
uh,
it's just a fucking killer album.
And,
and my favorite song on it is a song called moving out by Aerosmith.
uh,
it's great though.
It's just the production of it and everything.
It's just so fucking,
like,
it just sounded like they scraped their last couple of fucking dimes together
and put it out.
Um,
and I'm actually going to go to a fucking,
I'm going to go to a Meebo records today.
I'm going to fucking buy that album because,
uh,
I tried to download it on iTunes and they don't have it.
Isn't that a surprise?
Isn't that a fucking surprise?
Um,
I don't know who to blame on that one.
Is it Aerosmith?
Cause they're like,
well,
I don't like the production of that.
Or we have,
you know,
our two hits.
I was on like 47 different ever other compilations.
I don't know what,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm right now,
I'm going to put some money in those fuckers pockets,
download that whole album,
go out and buy it.
It's the shit.
They just to shit.
All right,
so where are we at here?
42 minutes in almost 43 minutes and I got to cover another fucking seven minutes
and then I can fucking,
uh,
can upload this fucking thing and get on with my God damn day here.
Oh,
by the way,
I'm going to be a Caroline's comedy club this week with a Paul Versey opening up
and in the middle,
young Joe to Rosa,
the teen idol sensation from the and Anthony Show.
I know a lot of you out there read teen beats,
so you're all up on Joe and his latest hairstyle,
but a,
for those of you not familiar with Joe,
um,
he has,
he has a wonderful spread coming out in a next next months,
uh,
teen beat anniversary issue where he's,
you know,
he's a swinging on a tire,
shirtless laying in a field,
very,
uh,
very Keith Partridge,
Shaun Cassidy,
sort of a photo shoot.
You know,
it's done a little bit ironic but a,
you know,
there's a lot of heart in it.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah,
I'm going to be there.
Uh,
what is it?
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
uh,
Thursday.
June 10th is my birthday by the way.
Okay,
so,
and I'm going to spend it on the road like some lonely sailor.
No,
actually I don't even know why I took the Gig on my birthday.
I know I did because I owe the tax man.
Yeah,
the tax man.
I don't know how you get rich in it and I know why people fucking steal from
people because that's the only way to get over the hump every time.
I think I'm going to get over the hump and I'm like,
mom,
on fucking easy street.
The fucking Goddamn IRS shows up,
you know,
gives me the fucking right there.
Fred,
the right there.
Fred and my fucking nuts right there,
Fred.
I just made my dog jumps.
Sorry about that dude.
Sorry,
I dare Fred.
That was actually a catchphrase in my family right there,
Fred,
and what that was.
That was actually from a Flintstones episode,
Flintstones episode where Fred was trying to fucking do a,
you guys have had that.
You ever just have a fucking like catchphrase and your family gets,
you know,
maybe you guys could send me into those.
I'll,
they'll,
I'll tell you.
One of ours,
one of ours,
and our family was called right there,
Fred.
Yeah.
Everything was going great than the two.
Gives me the fucking right there,
Fred.
And it was from the Flintstones and Fred,
I don't know what he's doing.
He was trying to impress Wilmoth that he learned how to do magic and he has this
egg.
Any gene does lean on a couple little dupes.
He dues and he's like,
all right,
well no,
where is it?
You know,
and he has his,
he has it like buried in his fist and she goes right there,
Fred and she fucking pounds.
She pounded his fist and broke the egg in his hand and exposed,
uh,
you know,
he thought he was the shit and she made an absolute fool out of him.
The proverbial yolk on your face,
but it was in his hand.
So that became,
that began enough.
They became the right there,
Fred and my family.
Anytime like,
you know,
you think you went in an argument,
you think?
Yeah.
Is there anything funnier than watching a big dog walk across hardwood floors?
I swear to God.
You think they're going across a minefield?
Clear.
What's wrong with you?
Huh?
You don't like walking across what happened to you?
Did you have a bad experience?
Okay.
All they have to say,
I don't have to say like the entire,
you want to go outside?
Oh,
I have to say is you want to inner ears come up,
Cleo.
You want to,
okay.
You want to go outside?
I'll see if I can get,
get her to how Cleo,
no,
no.
Damn Cleo,
you wanna go say
fuck she doing a little den.
Cleo,
you want to go inside?
Oh,
oh,
fucking awesome.
Is that if you guys don't have dogs,
I don't know why you don't have a dog and get a breed that fucking house.
I make it do that every time.
That was actually just
ah,
it's just fucking awesome.
Um,
anyways,
let's,
let's plow ahead.
What the hell was it?
I was talking about catchphrases,
but I was going to tell you something else.
I don't know.
I was speaking to my dog.
You know what I,
the my fucking landlord found out I had a dog.
Neither my landlord is listening to this podcast or the,
or the old fuck downstairs ratted me out.
I don't know what,
but I let it go.
I let it go cause you know,
make,
I have my coats.
I don't name names and I don't yell at old people.
All right.
I may talk shit about him on my podcast.
Hey,
remember that crazy lady,
that lady,
that crazy lady that I was telling you about my neighborhood.
Uh,
I was driving down the street the other day and I just saw her fucking laying on
the grass
screaming,
just fighting off like invisible.
I don't know what,
and uh,
I like,
I haven't left and I don't know how long it was so fucking funny.
I mean,
I feel bad for her and shit,
but like,
uh,
are you gonna stand like the street I live on is a quiet street and I'm driving
down this quiet street in my hybrid,
which is actually even quieter.
My hybrid,
the fucking Bose headphones of automobiles and it's just quiet.
You know,
I got the windows down.
It's the perfect day.
You don't need ac,
you don't need the windows up.
It's just why you live in California.
It's just fucking awesome day.
And you know,
fucking blue sky,
it's just,
just a beautiful day and I'm just cruising down the street could just got a
bunch of shit done.
I'm feeling good.
And all of a sudden I just,
I just,
you know,
as I'm coming up on her,
I can't see her because this car's parked in the side of the road.
I just say this or this faint like,
and I'm like to the,
you know,
it was so fucking bizarre.
I was like,
what the fuck is that?
And then I just like the ends up being like this just for car gap between cars
parked on the side of the road and I can't see this big SUV.
And right when I come around the side of it,
there's this crazy lady on her back,
like a fucking cock roach that can't get out.
She's like,
ah,
just flailing in slow motion.
I love Fred Sanford each limb one at a time.
And it was just so fucking bizarre,
but she was so committed and she was so into it.
And so just fighting something off.
It was,
it was just,
it was fucked.
Like it was so peaceful,
so beautiful.
What a day.
And all of a sudden I fucking drove by and I just started fucking laughing and
it was like,
it was just a guilt free laugh.
That was a guilt free left.
You know,
I didn't feel bad.
I feel bad that she's out there,
but like,
I like to think that I'm mature enough to know that either way.
That's funny.
Bright.
Am I a bad person?
I probably am.
I don't know.
Well that's the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
I didn't get back to the way that I didn't get back to the flyers.
Uh,
I didn't get back to,
you know,
I'm going to talk right until my phone call comes.
I got a phone call here at 11,
uh,
which is in four minutes.
Um,
what was I going to say?
I fucking,
uh,
getting back to the flyers and the,
the Blackhawks.
Okay.
It's a great series you guys really should watch right now.
Black Hawks just went up three,
two.
They are,
they are one game away.
Slick live little toy.
You know,
they always do that.
Yeah.
Quality eight months away from the ams in the curse.
Um,
from ending basically 50 years of frustration for these people.
Okay.
And,
uh,
you know,
to the fact that they have like,
some of the original players,
they have like five people left from their fucking team that aren't even dead
yet from the last time that they played.
MMM.
I'll tell you what's awesome is Bobby Hill.
Bobby Hill still looks like I can't figure out if he looks like,
if he'd still beat the shit out of you.
He looks like the comp.
He's in that weird aging process where he still looks like he could beat the
shit out of you yet.
He also looks like he signed the declaration and the Declaration of
independence,
which would have been hilarious if I didn't fucking stutter.
God Damn it.
I'm dumb.
Um,
so I gotta be honest with you.
I'm going to be happy for either a free the team.
It's going to be a shame that one of you guys had got to lose.
And uh,
you know,
I'm looking forward to more games.
Celtics,
Lakers,
uh,
got respect for the fucking Lakers,
man.
They're a hell of a squad.
And a,
I was off.
I was really off.
I've got to say it again.
I said Pago saw was going to get fucking raped in the NBA finals and uh,
I'm most impressed with him and Andrew,
uh,
buying them.
Is that his name?
Andrew.
I'm not a basketball guy.
I'm total bandwagon here.
I'm a fucking hockey guy.
Um,
for years people have been saying what the fuck this guy's going to do,
but he keeps hurting his knees and it seems like he's,
he's coming into his own and I don't know,
man.
It's going to be tough at the Celtic speed and it's going to be really fucking
impressive because,
uh,
I think they are younger and they're there quicker,
but we always find a way,
we find a way to win ugly.
That's what we do.
So we do.
What about ray ray reining in those threes?
You know,
and I had the whole game on mute.
I probably missed a lot of the excitement of listen to the crowd go crazy,
but I think I don't give a fuck.
That's how I have to do it so I can survive.
So are they have it?
That is the podcast for this week coming.
Uh,
come check me out of Caroline's this week in New York City.
Also next week I'm going to be at the Improv out here in Los Angeles,
Los Angles [inaudible] and uh,
I haven't put it up yet,
but I haven't.
Um,
for years people have been asking me to come out to San Diego and a,
I'm going to be at the La Jolla,
uh,
um,
comedy store the first weekend in August.
I don't have the fucking dates in front of me here.
Let me just check the map.
July,
August are the sixth and seventh.
I'm going to be out there.
So all you guys out there who've been asking me to come down there,
I'm finally coming down there.
I hope you show up.
Uh,
you can check out my new hours,
shit.
And as far as I know,
there might be right around the time when I let it go,
my special become an out on comedy central and then you'll watch it.
It'd be like,
Oh wow,
that fucking guy's hilarious.
I'm going to come down to see him in the club and I hit you over the head with
the new fucking hour cause that's how I do it.
All right,
you fucks.
Now I'm talking shit.
All right,
I'll see you guys next week.
Have a great week and get yourself a dog.
Get a big dog that tippy toes across the fucking a hardwood floors in Ohio for
you.
Once a day,
it'll keep you happy,
keep you happy.
You know
[inaudible]
[inaudible].